Ainsworth used three terms to describe her attachment theories. Secure
Attachment, Anxious Ambivalent Attachment and Avoidant Attachment. Given the
name, what do you think an Avoidant Attachment is? Is it this one, where the
babies cry and become very distressed when the caregiver leaves? But once the
caregiver returns, gives them warm hugs, and settles down fairly quickly. Is it
this one where the babies are distressed most of the time, especially when the
caregiver leaves. But when the caregiver returns the baby will go to the
caregiver but there won't be any warm hugs going on and the baby might even
push the caregiver away. Or Babies are not distressed at any time. Not when the
caregiver leaves, not when the caregiver returns, and there's no warm hugs or
affection at any time either. The caregiver is basically ignored. Give it your
best shot and select one.